[Music]
so with this new act there is a lot to
talk about astra finally got nerfed the
euro rework is here and it seems as
though brim and omen might be making a
return to the meta oh and did i mention
that ice box basically got fully
reworked well let's get into the patch
nets
[Applause]
valorem patch 4.04 just dropped and with
it came some game-changing tweaks but
most importantly astra finally got
nerfed players have been complaining
about just how oppressive astra has been
basically since she came out sure she
was nerfed back in patch 3.0 with added
cooldowns but it wasn't enough to stop
her from making our lives a living hell
dude i just hate astros
you can just have global presence or you
can like solo holes
imagine using four abilities all at the
same time yesterday's update addressed
many of these issues but let's start
with some of the bigger changes astra's
max amount of stars has been reduced to
4 and the cooldown on both her gravity
well and her nova pulse has been
increased from 25 seconds to a whopping
45. now players will have to be much
more critical when deciding when and
where to use her utility you can't just
kit dump her abilities anymore when
recalling her stars you will now have to
wait a full 25 seconds before you can
place them again the size of her gravity
well has also been changed from 525 to
but with her nebula increasing from 410
to 475 all this means is that her
utility is all now the exact same size
personally i think these are solid
changes previously asher was just way
too strong on certain maps and now
players will have to think a lot more
before placing her stars next riot moved
on to nerfing another top tier
controller viper viper's fuel now drains
50 faster when both her wall and smoke
are active and her fuel bar will turn
red when she doesn't have enough to
activate her abilities the cooldown
after deactivating both abilities has
also been increased by two seconds and
her snake bites now disappear one second
sooner needless to say riot definitely
wanted to make changes to the top tier
smoke agents now asher and viper weren't
the only ones who received updates both
omen and brim received some much needed
buffs the cooldown on omen smokes has
gone down from 40 seconds to 30 so
you'll have more opportunities to use
them as the round goes on but the
biggest change to his kit has to be the
travel time on his smokes the speed has
more than doubled from 2800 to 6400 and
these things can now fly across the map
almost instantly riot has also decreased
the cost of his teleport from 150 to 100
and lowered the pre-teleport delay from
1 second to 0.7 seconds
omen's paranoia has also been altered
slightly so we shouldn't get team
flashed as often now his smokes did go
up in price from 100 to 150 but given
the fact that they're the most important
part of his kit i think it's a pretty
fair trade-off next up we have brimstone
who i think received one of the most
interesting buffs in this entire patch
the deploy time on brim smokes has gone
down from two seconds to only one the
range on his ipad has increased from
5000 to 5500 and his smokes now match
the height of everyone else's but the
final change to brimstone is where
things get
kinda weird not only does brim's stim
beacon apply a 15 increase to your rate
of fire but it now also applies a 15
speed boost previously we saw this type
of mechanic applied in game modes like
spike rush so it'll be interesting to
see what it looks like in the real game
until then here's what the pros had to
say i'm gonna be honest i think i think
i think brimstone is better than omen
really good now i think it is i think it
really is sick
the fact that they nerfed
astra and they gave him movement speed
to his teammate like smoke down
it's pretty sick brimstone
i'll shoot hella fast liz and i tested
out brim's stim beacon with neon and no
the speed boost doesn't stack now before
we move on to icebox let's talk about
yoru we've known for a while now that
riot has been wanting to rework the
agent but that day is finally here his
underwhelming footsteps have been
replaced with a single yoru decoy which
can be sent running in any direction the
decoy has 150 hp and when shot it winds
up turns towards whoever shot it and
explodes in a cone area after a short
delay if you're caught within the cone
then you get flashed if you ask me this
ability is still kind of meh
if you're playing against half decent
players they probably won't even bother
shooting it but where his rework gets
really interesting is his teleport yoru
can purchase a second gate crash which
now resets every two kills rather than
being on a timed cooldown like before
and he can now fake his teleport the
audible range of gate crash has been
decreased from 22.5 meters to 12.5
meters and the speed that it travels has
also been increased from 675 to 800. oh
and did i mention that his alt now lasts
two seconds longer he's no longer
revealed to enemies while using it like
at all and now he can cast all of his
utility while it's active so i'll be
honest yoru sounds pretty [ __ ] strong
now it's tough to say if he's busted but
i'm sure we'll find out soon and since
i'm a plat scrub i decided to ask my boy
ethos about the changes because well
he's a yoru man
now
with the um with the fake out and the
the tp fake and also the speed of the tp
and how it's quieter and the alt don't
use gaming style is the most broken
thing in the world um he is now an
incredibly versatile and flexible agent
that can thrive in a lot more scenario
situations and environments that he
would struggle in
uh previously so
that was the biggest thing right like yo
could be great but only in like you know
one percent of scenarios now he can be
great in most scenarios and that's the
biggest that's the biggest impact
alright so lastly let's talk about the
box because the icebox that we all know
and love is basically gone
so riot says that these changes to the
corridor between garage and yellow
are to help attackers while also making
the space just a bit less claustrophobic
yellow has also been rotated so it's now
parallel with the edge of the map and
riot said that they just saw too many
rounds playing out where people would be
hiding behind yellow so now they shifted
it to the side they added a box here
which is similar to the box over here
and for those of you who don't know
it is wall bangable
you can wallbang this i think this
change to yellow is honestly great like
retaking is gonna be so much better now
and then we have the site itself so on b
site you can no longer hide down here in
this lower section it's completely
closed off the box that was here has now
been moved down there so you can
actually still plant here but there's no
box now though to keep you covered you
can go up top the rope is slightly
slightly uh moved over here and you can
also plan on the bridge now which is
kind of cool and then there's this
little spot here
so overall i think these changes are
going to be really good for attackers um
you can get onto the site easier and
there's different options to actually
plant now
um but what riot's done is actually
solid for defenders too like you'll
actually be able to retake now other
than that they made some minor changes
when you're entering kitchen here this
this angle is a bit different
and then boiler uh they shifted the ramp
over a little but other than that
nothing major and then on a site they
replaced the little box that was here
before with a full radii box which again
these are well bangable
overall i think these icebox changes are
pretty dope they give attackers more
options while still making things easier
for defenders on the retakes so good job
riot so aside from everything we've
already talked about riot also fixed the
way that certain abilities are placed on
the ground so now i don't have to maul
because my chamber utility didn't go
where i wanted it to alright so it's
safe to say that riot has really shaken
up the meta with this update like really
shaking it up with astra being nerfed
who knows now we might actually see some
variety in pro team comps i for one am
happy seeing players melt in astrid nade
combos or watching post plants get
stalled out because someone is sitting
off site and pulling people off to
diffuse is just boring we likely won't
be seeing this update in pro play for a
couple weeks now but with the first
masters event of the year coming up in
just a month and a half this could
change everything
so now i don't have to [ __ ] mauled
because my chamber utility didn't go
where i wanted it to
i didn't have to say but
i did it i i said a swear word but with
the first masters event of the year
coming up in just a month and a half
well then what then what this update can
change everything yeah
[Laughter]
okay